la batterie a retrouvé son public
mercredi 19 mai les équipes l'attendait
depuis des mois un spectacle surprise a
été organisée à l'auditorium objectif
fêter la réouverture et marquer le coup
l'événement a été improvisée à la
dernière minute face à l'incertitude
un spectacle d'une heure et demie monter
en une semaine on est dans
l'improvisation c'est vrai d'ailleurs le
décret sorti que ce matin un nul
permettant réellement et donc oui la
ville à la ville a souhaité marquer le
coup
on a on a des spectacles par exemple le
samedi qui sont qui sont dans la
programmation officielle mais là on
voulait être au rendez-vous de cette
date importante
au programme contes improvisation danse
ou encore ciné concert une douzaine
d'artistes s'est succédé sur la scène
dans des univers et style est différent
c'est le cas du groupe la brise du
mammouth prévenu une semaine avant et
face à l'incertitude
ils n'ont pu répéter qu'une fois avant
le spectacle les artistes étaient
pourtant ravi de performer à nouveau
devant un public
ça fait plaisir c'est vrai que ça fait
ça fait longtemps donc ça fait un peu
bizarre tout début le premier morceau on
fait un peu rouillé quoi mais ouais
c'est vraiment sympa quoi pouvoir
rejouer enfin je crois que nous on avait
envie de rejouer mais je pense que les
gens aussi avait envie de le revoir un
peu de groupes en live donc tout le
monde était motivé protocole sanitaire
oblige et la salle a ouvert avec 35% de
la jauge 80 spectateurs ont été
accueillis sur place
côté programmation d'autres concerts et
événements sont prévus 4 juin
effectivement il ya un duo avec jean
marie machado très très grand pianiste
aussi au jardin d'hermitage le soir et
le lendemain matin samedi 5 juin une
conférence circonférence donc à
l'auditorium de l'école de musique par
andré minvielle sur l'idée de désaxant
dans le monde
leur lien avec les musiques le 5 juin
après midi un bal sera organisé au
jardin de l'héritage
[Musique]